une étoile à vichy genre je donne le
danseur vedette de béjart par ailleurs
héros du film de lelouch les uns et les
autres a décidé de s'installer en france
à vichy précisément une aubaine pour la
ville
reportage jean-claude dario jorge donn
la quarantaine juvénile 25 ans de
carrière internationale 25 ans de gloire
sur les plus grandes scènes du monde
sous la houlette de maurice béjart est
au coeur des vallées du xxème siècle il
a contribué à rendre populaire la danse
classique aujourd'hui pour lui une
nouvelle heure a sonné sans rompre avec
son passé il veut voler de ses propres
ailes
il a choisi vichy pour créer sa propre
compagnie une démarche normale pour un
danseur de génie mais pourquoi vichy pas
ici baby sitter rencontre avec la
compagnie fermière qui sont en projet à
ses immenses dans cette ville
écoutez faudrait pour une ville et la
lui de faire une compagnie j'ai
travaillé avec des gens
m
jorge donn directeur artistique de ce
qui s'appellera demain le vichy balle
est un pari mais aussi la première
pierre culturel d'un projet énorme dont
on voit ici en exclusivité la maquette
un projet qui fera de vichy la capitale
européenne de la santé et de la mise en
forme en 1990 nous allons investir 240
millions de francs contre le milliard de
centimes plus rénover complètement le
patrimoine de l'état qui existent
aujourd'hui à vichy et avec l'aide de
l'état à investir 200 millions à nouveau
ce qui fait un total de 440
prochain rendez vous avec jorge donn ées
son nouveau ballet septembre 1988 les
sponsors du vie chez new look ont décidé
de ne pas lésiner sur les moyens
jorge donn aura la possibilité d'engager
les meilleurs professionnels du monde de
la danse